des ateliers pour apprendre aux enfants
à philosopher la ministre déléguée
chargée de la ville s'est rendu auprès
des enfants deux trappes pour assister
aux ateliers à visée philosophique
il permet aux enfants d'apprendre à
débattre et à dialoguer dans un cadre
démocratique pour leur apprendre à se
questionner pour l'art apprendre à se
débattre à débattre pardon entre pourra
prendre justement à respecter les uns et
les autres les points de vue est
également livrée le maximum au maximum
un esprit critique permettre à nos plus
jeunes d'avoir du recul d'avoir le
d'acquérir le sens de la réflexion le le
questionnement pour les aider dans ce
parcours de la construction à la
citoyenneté
qu'est ce que le bonheur quelle est la
différence entre les garçons et les
filles
les ateliers permettent aux enfants de
débattre sur des questions qui les
préoccupent la disent ce qu'ils pensent
et pise écoute les autres ils apprennent
à développer une argumentation pas
simplement dire moi je pense ça c'est
tout non pourquoi tu penses à donc on va
développer la raison l'argumentation et
puis la qualité d'écouté cirque les
enfants apprennent à s'écouter et puis
souvent ils changent d'avis battue m'a
convaincu et donc on pourrait dire que
c'est une sorte de laboratoire de
citoyenneté autre visée acquérir le sens
de l'écouté montrer aux enfants qu'on
pense mieux ensemble
ça donne aux enfants un sens du bien
commun un sens du collectif
un sens du débat constructif plutôt que
de dire à l'autre
finalement c'est c'est un danger et
c'est un nom l'otm enrichi depuis le
lancement 900 ateliers ont été
pratiquées à trappes 3500 sur l'ensemble
du territoire le ministère de la ville
et l'association sève ont signé une
convention à l'école jean baptiste
clément pour déployer plus largement ces
ateliers endroit où l'expérimentation
avait eu lieu il y a trois ans il me
semblait évidemment tout naturel de
venir signer la convention qui permettra
de déployer ces ateliers partout en
france les liens dans la première école
qui a vu justement cette rencontre se
concrétiser la convention permet à
l'association sève en charge des
ateliers d'être soutenus financièrement
pendant trois ans une subvention totale
de 1,2 million d'euros qui permettra à
plusieurs sites et éducative de profiter
de ces ateliers